welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season 2 is taking shape
as a hunt for one of the earliest Kang
variants Victor timely where in the
world is Victor timely actually they did
a Time version of Carmen San Diego so
wasn't it where in time is Victor timely
I'm gonna stop singing now of all the
kings we met in the post credit scenes
of Ant-Man that was quantumania this
1901 Thomas Edison figure with his
astounding temporal Marvels definitely
has us the most curious as it is now
being a burn to be an actual scene from
season 2 of Loki written and directed by
that crew not by the quantumania team so
secretive that Marvel will not even tell
us what episode it's from because that
apparently will be a spoiler let's just
hope it is from the episode that you
know is actually in the season you know
we've been tricked before it hurts you
know it hurts like getting burned out of
time hurts but Loki and Moby is
targeting Victor timely in particular
actually plugs in with a lot of what we
know about Loki season 2 and really
provides the missing link that
crystallizes the plot structure of the
upcoming season by the way subscribe to
our new channel live where I did an
insanely detailed look back into Loki
season 1 and it could support our
growing Network by grabbing some merch
at nerdright.shop like something from
the deep dive collection okay to quickly
recap the second post credit scene we
find ourselves in an early 20th century
exhibition Hall I've seen some people
call this the 1920s but I think 1920s is
just what people who didn't pay
attention during a push call anything
pre-depression these aren't Flappers
Sunny this is Victorian eragarb which
means turn of the century we're talking
Rose's mom in Titanic which does line up
nicely with the 1901 date that is often
used with Victor timely from the comics
here Victor steps out on a stage with an
instrument that looks like the rings of
an engine all pulled apart some kind of
cylindrical object off on the side a
banner reads Victor timely and his
astounding tempura Marvels Victor says
time is everything it shapes our lives
but perhaps we can drape it I will admit
my precious what Jonathan majors does
pale's in comparison but I just love the
choices he makes I cannot help but try
to do them myself but Loki and Mobius
are in the crowd and Lucy's says it's
him Moby says you made him sound like
this terrifying figure wow and Loki says
he is Peyton wreath confirmed to any
wire that this is a scene from Loki
season 2 and that Jonathan Majors was
going for a period voice in his words
Frederick Douglass hair Frederick
Douglass was an abolitionist a writer
and orator one of the most prominent men
of his time in the late 19th century in
the real world historical timeline is
really the heart of the Loki series
remember season one touched on the real
life historical events like the eruption
of Mount Vesuvius over Pompeii in 79 A.D
the hijacking of flight 305 by DB Cooper
in 1971 the urban legend of the USS
Eldridge in the Philadelphia Experiment
from 1943 and then extrapolated forward
into the future to all the natural
disasters that will happen over the next
50 years but now it seems like season
two is gonna extrapolate that further
back to the way Kang variants have
already influenced world history the
interesting thing about Victor timely is
that he is actually one of the disguises
that Kang wears an attempt to hide in
plain sight as opposed to Kang taking on
a new out and proud villainous form like
immortus ferrarama tent or Scarlet
Centurion who by the way that
futuristicang was confirmed to be based
on according to Peyton Reed even though
he looks absolutely nothing like Scarlet
Centurion but Victor and timely first
appeared in the 1992 Captain America
annual number 11. the citizen Kang
storyline in which this Kang variant
establishes the town of timely Wisconsin
and runs it as its mayor an inventor an
industrialist who specializes in
technology in robotics while he was
introducing this Advanced Tech to the
people of timely secretly this Kang was
building his Base City of Kannapolis
just slightly out of sync with the time
stream right beside chronopolis making
it fall within a paradox and be fully
undetectable during this time keng's
longtime love interest of a Rona rinse
Lair begins living with Victor timely
going under the pseudonym of Rebecca
tormente the same name that we should
note the Loki finale made sure to
display on rince lair's past life
diploma in her school principal office
it's also worth noting that Victor
timely employed a young doctor Phineas
Horton in the comics Vinnie swartner
would one day create the original Human
Torch and that the robotics technology
that Victor developed during these years
included a fail safe that would later
get encoded into every Sentinel you know
the X-Men Hunters so that later when the
government tries to deploy Sentinels
during the Kang Dynasty storyline Kang
commandeers they said
and turns him back against Earth I think
all of this is going into Victor timely
in season 2 of Loki and this moment with
Loki and Mobius will either be the
opening scene of the Season maybe the
cold open from which we will flash back
into where season one left off in the
TVA or maybe this scene will be the
final scene of season 2 episode 1 but
it's going to be a significant moment
what we don't know yet is whether Victor
timely always existed in MCU history the
one that we've watched or only now just
spawn into existence as a result of
Sylvie's actions in the season 1 finale
both options could be hinted at to be
simultaneously true like if my theory is
true that Avengers Tower is occupied by
Mr Griffin CEO of Kang Enterprises the
MCU never really has to state if he was
there right after Spider-Man homecoming
before the events of Loki season 1
occurred or not it would kind of be hard
to even say that because all of Loki
season 1 took place outside of time
there's really a branch extracted from
2012 but even that Branch was pruned
really everything that happened in Loki
took place outside of time and affected
all of time at once but really the
question is did Victor timely and the
other kangs influence the other MCU
events that we have seen well at least
some of them yes Rama Tut appeared on
that Cairo kids jacket Moon Knight so
the world of Moon Knight was at least in
part shaped by Kang and if they keep
that Phineas Horton connection from the
comics Phineas Horton's name appeared
alongside Howard Stark at the 1943 Stark
Expo in the first Captain America film
so the earliest Stark technology from
that era like think about the mysterious
Vita rays that were used to enhance
Steve Rogers into Captain America Super
Soldier program Tech that also gave us
the Hulk all of Shield's Weaponry all
Avengers really could be rooted in
Victor timely technology that is why I
think Loki and Mobius are seeking Victor
timely in particular you know the other
kings like Rama Tut they seek to conquer
ancient Egypt and only get so far but
Victor timely picked the dawn of the
20th century and he laid low he got way
further just as a man behind the curtain
he is really what set off the chain
reaction of events that led to the super
soldier program High drug The Avengers
Initiative Earth getting in the
crosstairs of Thanos and most
importantly for his own existence Tony
Stark cracking the code to time travel
with the inverted Mobius strip now I
have speculated that Victor timely in
the town of timely Wisconsin could
actually be the origin of the TVA as we
know it that origin was a big mystery
deliberately raised and never answered
in season one I'd like all files
pertaining to the creation of the TV8
those are classified
I need all the files on the founding of
the TBA everything from the beginning of
time well that's a mighty tall order
some things had to get worked out but
I'm downloading the files you need now
this isn't what I asked for I know but
he thinks this will be more useful I
believe that Victor timely might have
been an alias used by he who remains
which speaks to why he's such a showman
on that stage like the other kangs are
either really quiet and Regal or real
Rowdy and Untamed but both Victor timely
and he remains our performers who hit
their marks I think the device on that
stage might actually be the first
prototype of the reset charge in that
Victor timeline we'll use this to erase
the town of timely out of the timeline
and use it to build his TDA because
notice that Victor timely like he who
remains Bears no facial scarring like
most other kangs do I think that's
because all the others have cybernetic
Parts Kang the Conqueror has his
neurokinetic implants ramatut leaves
assault is half Android and this could
actually explain why Scarlet Centurion
was given this weird robotic body this
could all connect to why when Loki was
first processed through the TVA there
was an entire stage devoted to
determining whether or not you were a
robot he remains Victor timely not
robots they were the Kang that invented
all other robotics at Future Avengers
and X-Men Fantastic Four and Kang
dynasty members use and so season two of
Loki will be a scavenger hunt through
history of 20th century American
Technology in the real world and in the
MCU weapons Tech and consumer Tech to
show how it all had the signature of one
man hey a reminder to subscribe to our
new channel the Deep dive and it can
support us by grabbing some merch over
at nerdriot.shop you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at eat a boss
following the rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign